à bristol est classé six ans aux cheveux
fous et donc ça c'est une peine
d'emprisonnement ferme intention adacore
35 euros c'est si vous ne présentez pas
le pass c'est en l'occurrence
effectivement là on est sur une ondée
sur une autre action pénale de fond
d'écriture si vous nous regardez
six mois d'emprisonnement et 3750 euros
d'amendé ça peut aller jusqu'à 4,5 me
alors oui bah tu es moins bien je m'en
fous de la mode moi ce que voilà
pourquoi je suis c'est très très grand
ducaux fait il ya deux façons de vivre
en société le passé n'étaient on est
vaccinés ou sinon on fait affaire tous
les trois jours je pense pas que vous le
fassiez sinon qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire que si tu est porteur tu
vas croisé quelque part où c'est déjà
peut-être c'est une vieille dame dans la
rue ou quelqu'un qui est malade et qui
elles vont mourir c'est à dire qu'au
moment où on se parle aujourd'hui tu as
peut-être déjà tué quelqu'un vous il ya
quelqu'un qui est très très très mal et
tu ne sais pas
si nous on a huit fois moins de chances
de le donner mais vous allez finir ce
mois ci qu'il n'est pas un test tous les
jours quand tu vas troisième vieille
dame ou quelqu'un de fatigué la tuer
pensant que comme au genre ayant pas
sanitaire vous n'avez pas besoin de
faire de test pour le coc vite vous
pouvez dans le temps plutôt navy fois
moins 90% de chances de moins de le
transmettre quand on est vacciné même si
on l'a que quelqu'un qui les prennent
mais
pourquoi ces débats sont sous l'angle et
sont pas selon vous est arrivé là mais
vous comprenez rien et sont celles en
coûtait moi pourquoi vous êtes sous
lampe à ce que vous racontez n'importe
que c'est toi alors amateurs de langue
et et calmez vous avec moi
[Applaudissements]
liberté j'ai absolument aucune leçon à
recevoir de vous vu effectivement les
conneries que vous débitez à longueur
d'émissions à l'étranger monsieur on
n'est pas libre ans oscillant mais sinon
j'adore rouler à 300 alors sur
l'autoroute
atteinte à ma liberté un désaccord vous
avez vu ces violences
vous voulez bien évité d'employer des
mots dont deux contre des pales sont ce
qu est ce que vous y connaissez à la
liberté mais vous aurez que toi contre
n'importe quoi deux minutes à venir
faire des débats philosophiques le seul
mec libre ici pardon mais c'est moi
parce que moi j'assume jusqu'au bout en
fait et je viens pas effectivement vous
donner des leçons qu'elle quelle soit
vous passez votre temps à donner des
leçons
non mais attendez vous passez votre
temps à donner des leçons à tout le
monde moi j'ai dit ce monsieur est
effectivement que je ne cautionnais pas
ce qu'ils faisaient mais je n'ai aucun
jugement à porter parce que guillaume
guillaume genton est vrai quand vous
avez des mesures absurdes quand vous
avez mesure complètement con faut pas
vous étonner que les gens réagissent de
manière conne enfin je veux dire à un
moment donné merde quoi papa sanitaire
est juste bien
sûr je suis qui grèvent non c'est pas la
question dans son génie
je fais pas un truc que je ferai pas le
sujet faire un truc que je ferais pas la
preuve que je suis libre c'est que je
vais pas débattre avec vous
parce que s'il ya bien un truc que j'ai
pas envie de faire c'est perdre mon
temps